all right we are live how how are you
today I'm wondering if you can just
start by telling us how you're holding
up and how life has changed for you in
the past couple of months well I was
actually on a tour stopping by in
California and then going on to Las
Vegas and then Russia and Minsk and
Eastern Europe so I got locked down here
but I'm using my time well I'm engaged
in social media trying to help people
decrease the inflammation after immune
response and in turn I'm taking care of
myself
reinventing my body resurrecting myself
well we are gonna talk about all of that
and we're very grateful to you for
making the time during what I imagine is
a very busy season for you in life I
just want to introduce ourselves to our
audience really quickly my name is
Madison Mills I'm a reporter with
Bloomberg and I'm joined here by Deepak
Chopra a spiritual icon who is here
today to talk with us about mental
health and managing stress and anxiety
during the pandemic so I also want to
remind our audience that if you have any
questions please comment with them and
we will talk about as many as we can
but first I want to get to a question
that a lot of people have right now
which is about managing stress I'm
wondering if you can just talk about
some simple techniques people can employ
to navigate their stress and anxieties
right now sure the medicine stresses the
perception of threat I'll repeat that
stress is the perception of threat it
doesn't matter what the threat is
financial threat threat of disease
threat of mortality psychological threat
but it's your interpretation of threat
and when you have stress there are two
kinds one is acute stress - chronic
stress actually chronic stress is all
was considered more dangerous than acute
stress chronic stress is minor things
that bug you every time you know
so-and-so cut the lines
so blew their horn at me
road rage argument with your significant
other with your children etc that
chronic stress is associated with
chronic inflammation in the body and
immune compromised ation and associated
with most chronic illnesses like
diabetes heart disease hypertension
cancer stroke etc they all have some
degree of stress and chronic
inflammation now what is happening is on
top of that an acute stress acute means
immediate fear of of an anxiety around
our personal safety
so exists tential threat exists
seneschal suffering in the back of the
mind the fear of death and what we are
finding through our search engines is
that the people who are really getting
sick are having what are called
inflammatory storms in their body acute
inflammatory storm like everything goes
crazy in their body in terms of
information because of the acute fear
and stress there this is driven in the
body by a part of the brain nervous
system called the autonomic nervous
system and something called the
sympathetic overdrive so the sympathetic
nervous system goes out of whack so to
speak there's another system in the body
which is does the opposite it creates
resilience adaptability and actually
helps you manage your stress and that
system is called the parasympathetic
nervous system as opposed to the
sympathetic nervous system the
parasympathetic nervous system can be
activated through meditation through
mindfulness through deep breathing
through yoga you know postures of yoga
they stimulate different parts of the
vagus nerve vagus nerve is related to
the English word vagabond it goes
everywhere in the body from the brain
and it's the healing nerve in the body
the self regulation nerve in the body
every time you practice meditation
mindful awareness yoga
deep breathing or you engage in healthy
emotions like love compassion joy
equanimity entertainment like humor you
actually stimulate the opposite nerve to
distress nerve which I'm calling the
lunatic now and so this is an
opportunity for everyone to actually
heal stress maximize their immune
capacity because the immune system is
very complicated it's not that you have
to boost your immune system an
overactive immune system can cause
autoimmune illness and allergy and under
active immune system makes you
predisposed to infections possibly even
cancer so you don't need an overactive
aggressive immune system that would be
going back to austerity you don't need
an under active immune system you need
to fine-tune the business and for that
you need good sleep you need meditation
you need good relationships healthy
environment and you need to have fun
that doesn't matter what it is if you
have children then play with them sing
to them entertain them watch funny
movies with them listen to fairy tales
with them ask them to imagine amazing
things the worst use of imagination the
worst use of imaginations of stress the
best use of imagination is creativity
and opportunity this is the time well
that was a over would say a tweetable
comment I really that really resonated
with me I'm wondering you mentioned the
idea of grief I'm wondering if you can
talk a bit about how people can navigate
feelings of grief in a time of just so
much uncertainty okay so when you study
grief you see that it almost universally
follows certain stages grief occurs when
there's loss so what we've lost right
now is a way of living that we took for
granted and now it's gone so we are
experiencing the grief that way of
living for now anyway it's not
there will be a new way of living we
will figure it out but the what we were
used to you know immediate taking
flights every we're going to crowded
places irrespective of traffic density
hygienic conditions all that fun when
people experience grief they they go
through these following following stages
first is they feel victimized they say
why me well in this case it's everyone
it's not just you okay it's the rich the
poor everyone I was getting that
although some people are at more at risk
of course so first thing is
victimization second stages anger people
get angry and even get hostile then the
third stages they feel frustrated
the fourth stages they start to get into
the place of helplessness and
resignation this is a very critical
space some people succumb to
helplessness and resignation they are
the ones who get acute stress some
people find acceptance which is
different than resignation or
helplessness the acceptance means okay
this is what it is now how do I deal
with it I as a physician have seen
people going through these stages when
they're dying say of a heart attack look
very in one are they go through all
these stages and then suddenly there's
the acceptance not in everyone some and
when you see acceptance there's peace
and once there's peace then there's
meaning so right now this is the stage
where it we're in a stage between
acceptance and resignation and yet not
in the stage of meaning we need to ask
ourselves what is the meaning of my life
right now Who am I
beyond the experience of this body mind
Who am I as a spirit as a soul what do I
really want in my life
in the life of my friends and my family
and my community and ultimately for the
world what is our purpose what is a
higher calling right now because
we are being asked right now what is the
meaning of this and unless you find the
meaning there won't be that higher
calling so right now is what the ancient
wisdom traditions say opportunity and
preparedness the preparedness has to be
you have to be centered in yourself you
have to be in touch with your soul and
you have to ask these questions Who am I
what do I want what's my purpose what am
i grateful for in fact even in this
situation if you ask yourself what am i
grateful for suddenly everything seems
different if you look at the world
through the eyes of gratitude it looks
actually pretty good right now the birds
are singing the sky is clear the stars
can be seen at night fish are returning
to dead lake birds are singing Hyderabad
you can see the Himalayas from hundreds
of miles away so what is the existence
what is nature saying to us saying
humans take a little time reflect in
your cages and when you come back treat
us with little more respect little more
you know we need to have a sacred
relationship with existence period not
just our existence all existence
absolutely and and this idea of finding
your purpose I think some people are
struggling with a little more right now
because the future is so uncertain so
it's hard to you know plan and have you
know a Type A approach to our futures
right now what advice you have for that
ya know you don't need to plan for your
future right now what you need to be is
present to what is and then ask
meaningful questions and if you ask
those questions
don't worry about the answers then life
will move you into the answers this is
the ancient wisdom tradition from east
and west from Buddha to Plato from
Socrates to Jesus Christ okay
literally everyone has told us if you
surrender to the wisdom of uncertainty
right now you will find your creativity
ask yourself what are my unique skills
what are my unique talents how can I
serve how can I help create love in
action because love without action is
meaningless action without
is the relative once you adopt that
mantra in your mind love in action
suddenly the door opens for opportunity
now all this sounds new-age you know
[ __ ] if you want to call it whatever
you know but it's not it's the very best
wisdom that has come to us and survived
for thousands of years and if we listen
to this live the question who are we
what's our purpose what's our calling
what responsibility can we take how can
we execute love in action and love in
action doesn't mean I have to give you
money what if I had the money I should
give it to you if you need it and you
should ask for it and if I mean the
money I should ask for it now is the
time to actually expose our
vulnerabilities help each other but we
can help each other just by paying
attention to each other just by telling
each other we care for each other just
by accepting each other as we are so as
long as you practice acceptance
appreciation attention and affection
we're going to solve this we're going to
come out stronger but to start to plan
the future when actually the only
reality is the uncertainty that would be
foolhardy you know actually at all times
the only reality is uncertainty if I
asked you to predict what's going to
happen in the world in the next one hour
you wouldn't be able to do it right so
embrace the wisdom of uncertainty that's
what creativity's absolutely that's
that's incredible advice and I do want
to get to some audience questions we're
getting for you as well one audience
member is asking how can I find
work/life balance when work is now at
home I'm doing exactly what I would do
if I was going out to work so I work
eight hours a day and I pretend that I'm
in my office right now this is a little
makeshift office well I am in miles but
then I do the same thing I just like I
find focused work time focused
relationship time focus eating time
focused downtime
focused entertainment time
focus please time and the day goes by
like a blast is your day really
scheduled out that way it happened you
know I started my David for intentions
joyful energetic body loving
compassionate heart reflective alert
mind and lightness of being an eeling to
the world and then I leave those
intentions and then my day automatically
moves around those it goes for
intentions sure sure and how many years
has it been of you meditating every
single day over 40 right 25 years 50
almost yeah oh my that one must my I
sense my truth since I was in my
twenties yeah and I'm wondering if you
can just talk to us about you know first
just the definition of meditation and
how people can start to practice it
while they're at home during during this
pandemic so meditation has a rich
tradition all across the world there are
meditations that are called reflective
self inquiry like asking questions that
we did Who am I what do I want what am i
grateful
then there are awareness meditation
awareness of the breath or awareness of
the sensations in the body or awareness
of a thought or awareness of an emotion
or awareness of the web of relationship
and then there's meditations that take
you with mantra beyond thoughts to the
source of thought so it's pretty rich
the the the body of techniques in
meditation throughout centuries is very
rich east and west these days what
people call mindfulness is actually
awareness more than anything else the
awareness of authority commandeth art
then when you become aware that you are
the awareness behind the thought then
you don't need to identify with the part
because most thoughts are recycled
through social media and news that
whatever actually less than 1% of your
thoughts a year or so
you can dismiss let it go meditation is
a way to go beyond thought now for those
who are beginners we have with Oprah
Winfrey we have a meditation hope in
uncertain times the 321 days of
meditation you can go online Chopra
Center meditation calm and there are
hundreds of meditations we made
available through YouTube and through
social media where people can start to
choose their favorite meditation then
also guided meditations so it's very
rich people can do what they want if
they don't want to do anything extensive
they can just sit quietly for 5 minutes
close their eyes and watch their breath
that's a good start or when they are
stressed they can just stop take 3 deep
breath well observe what's happening in
their body and proceed with the
conscious choice these are all forms of
meditation absolutely and is this
something that you think folks with kids
at home can participate in as well as
this kid-friendly the idea of meditation
if your kids are less than 5 please
don't introduce the idea of meditation
play with them entertain them sing with
them dance with them watch good funny
movies with them make them laugh that's
good meditation for them and for you if
you are centered the kids will follow
that if you can talk all you want but if
you are not centered the kids won't
listen to you so you know there's a
phenomenon children called mirror
neurons the neurons mirror the neurons
of their caretakers even pets by the way
dogs and cats they mirror the neurons of
their human companions so if you're new
you're Artic your children will be
neurotic your pets will dinner if you're
centered calm settle your pets and your
kids will be fine
you don't have to worry about them take
care of yourself and your presence will
heal people otherwise you can talk and
do all the philosophy you want but the
kids don't listen to that right and this
idea of taking care of yourself is so
important I'm wondering for parents who
you know are just dealing with working
at home and having their kids and the
dinners and everything how can they
start to practice
just taking care of themselves a little
bit I think the most important thing is
trying to get good sleep number one
number two make sure even at home that
you stand up and walk for a little bit
every hour third engage with your
friends that you're sheltered with you
know you with your friends
I'm family if you have sheltered with
your friends and family engage socially
with them but if you are not then engage
with them online for you know the data
suggests the more you engage the better
use this so even if it's gossip doesn't
matter whatever it is the more you
engage with people the better you feel
so right now is the you know again
the data shows even up to six hours of
social engagement is good for you
okay so social isolation is actually
very harmful physical social - isolation
is not something that humans and mammals
are used to be used to touching cuddling
kissing cooing licking all that you know
that makes a human being a mammal normal
so when you cut that off it's a huge
huge issue which causes stress but we
have to do it right now but doesn't mean
we can't be intimate without touching
each other we can be intimate with
ourselves we can be intimate with other
people all we have to do is what I call
the forest attention listening affection
caring appreciation being grateful and
acceptance don't try to change me or fix
the world fix yourself right now mmm and
you mentioned gratitude can you give our
viewers some advice about how they can
be better about practicing gratitude
during this time so here's what we did
with some of our clients at the center
and some of our retreats we told them
before you go to sleep at night just
write down what am i grateful for on the
piece of paper what am i grateful for
what what happened today that's it don't
worry about the future learn about past
what am i grateful for today and just
write down
whatever comes to mind and behold what
happened the inflammation went down
their body relaxed homeostasis got
triggered in homeostasis and
self-regulation so gratitude is the
easiest thing to do what am i grateful
for write down whatever comes to your
mind and you'll feel better not only
mentally but biologically that's great
advice and you've spoken also a lot on
your podcast about navigating
relationships right now a lot of people
are living in very close quarters with
family or roommates or what have you
what advice you have for folks on how
they can safely navigate those dynamics
if you don't fix your relationships now
when you have the opportunity then for
the rest of your life you will never be
able to fix your relationship now is the
opportunity and I think the sequences
empathy empathy means feeling what the
other person feels but then compassion
which means the desire to alleviate
their suffering because when you
alleviate their suffering you will leave
e8 your suffering so empathy leads to
compassion compassion leads to love and
love must be accompanied by some action
but as I said without action it's
meaningless
so some action whatever it is a gesture
sentence or some kind of action which
shared the cells that you mean what you
say it's not just otherwise I love you
is the cliche right everybody says I
love it right so sure absolutely this
moment where we're all at home this is a
good moment to practice you don't fix it
now then come back every time giving
insight right with you and we this
reminds me of another audience question
we have which is are there any possible
long-term effects of not having any
social interaction and I'm wondering
just your thoughts on whether this
moment could potentially you know
retrain our brains to think differently
now that we're just experiencing so much
a long time everything
experience that we have actually is
recorded by the brain every experience
and every experience is recorded by the
brain affects the body there's no
separation and everything that happens
in the body affects your relationships
with the world so it's all one process
okay right now the only thing that
should be important for us is to
actually recognize that we are a web of
relationships there's no meat without
the other there is no me without the
other okay so let's let's get that and
if we get that by healing others we can
heal ourselves and on your podcast you
spoke so beautifully about how a
relationship isn't about you do this for
me and I do this for you it's the
experience of it can you can you expand
on that a little bit because I just that
really resonated with me well a
relationship is is the movement of
giving and receiving they can't be
bought in one kind you can't have one
without the other
but the giving is what causes the
receiving if you think only about
yourself
you'd be stressed next time you address
ask yourself Who am I thinking about
that's it and you realize you're only
thinking about yourself as soon as you
switch to thinking about the other you
feel better immediately so the key to
relationship is give give give give and
the receiving is a circulation of the
giving period whatever you want give it
if you want love give it if you want
abundance be abundant in and generous in
your giving to the extent that you can
afford it
but make that the mantra again ask and
you shall receive
ask whom yourself and ask what what do I
want what do you want do you want just
more money I do you want a better life
you know what is what is a better life
it's yes money is important but you know
all when you look at the happiness of
demographics happiness is dependent on
three things the choices you make
number one your attitude to life whether
it's an opportunity or it's a blessing
or a disaster and the third thing is
making other people happy that's it
that's the key to happiness your
attitude is it an opportunity or is it a
disaster how can I help what's the
meaning of relationship and financial
conditions are part of that but you know
only 10 to 15 percent of our happiness
comes from financial security the
remaining 80% or more comes from our
attitude to life and our relationships
so if your relationships our number one
priority you'll be a happy person
beautiful again that's it beautifully
said and we only have a couple minutes
left with you so I just want to end by
asking about you know this is affecting
all of us personally I'm wondering how
you are finding moments of joy
throughout your day right now and how
you're kind of defining that you know
I'm busy engaged right now with mental
health and awareness and bringing people
we have a campaign called never alone
dot love anyone can go into that and
participate online communities offline
communities through the Chopra
foundation so I'm pretty busy right now
and then you know I'm only thinking and
how can we help people during this
mental awareness month and you have to
realize that it's not about being a
positive minders can also be a stressful
mind you need a quiet mind a quiet mind
is a healthy mind so we need to practice
mental hygiene that's what we're
encouraging people and helping people
with at the moment absolutely and just
to close our time out with you I want to
ask about you know a lot of people are
feeling a bit of pressure right now to
work on themselves and use this time at
home for self improvement and they're
almost stressing themselves out with the
idea of bettering themselves
how can people navigate that the
acceptance of who you are right now
a desire to grow people get stressed
about everything they get stressed about
vacations you know they stress about
vacation which is supposed to be an
enjoyable time planning the vacation
wondering if they're really having a
good time then trying to remember all of
that don't need to do anything you just
need to relax let it be settle into your
being and ask yourself what am I feeling
right now and you can switch a feeling
by the way instantly if you meet your
body and you remember an experience of
love period if you feed your body and
remember an experience whether it's your
newborn child or whether you fell in
love for the first time or when you
thought of your parents or when you
looked at the Grand Canyon you felt
something remember that and feel it
again and you will instantly shift your
state of being there's nothing to do
just shift your state of being there's
no way to go you're already there
absolutely well I think that's a
beautiful thing to end on just reminding
our audience to think of a moment of
love and bliss and live in that moment
for a bit Emelia body and feel your body
which is helped by meditation correct
yes
wonderful well Deepak Chopra we are so
grateful for your time I know you're
busy and thank you to our audience for
joining us have a wonderful rest of your
day thank you so much thank you much
bye-bye